foreign
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
this meeting of baber District Council
cabinet I'm councilor John Ward leader
of baby District Council and I will be
chairing this meeting
may I remind you of some domestic
Arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
do not interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations whilst others are
speaking
if you're attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off
finally we will be using e-voting for
this meeting on the modern.gov app so
please commend us make sure they are
logged in and ready to use the app
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented beat to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
I'll now move to the agenda item one
apologies for absence
thank you chair we have received
apologies from Council milvisi
thank you item two to receive
Declarations of pecunery other
registerable or non-registerable
interests by members are there any to
declare
members
okay thank you item three
paper BCA 2224 to confirm the minutes of
the meeting held on the 5th of September
2022 so I'll just go through some Page
by piece on page one
page two
page three
page four
page five
Page Six
page seven
page eight
page nine
and I understand there that there is one
correction in item 46.6 where it says
the cabinet member for the environment
it should say climate change
biodiversity and sustainable transport
and lastly page 10.
Castle Osborne
thank you Mr chairman actually saw you
have page seven
um of the report 42.5
uh the last paragraph she ensured it
should be assured members at the
government would be fully informed of
the rent situation that should be that
members will be fully informed of the
rent situation
Newcastle Osborne
okay
if enough further questions may have a
proposal please
councilor McLaren seconder
castle gold
okay
take the vote for the minutes please
thank you members that vote is now in
progress
foreign
votes four that's unanimous thank you
item four to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
Castle's petition scheme none received
item five questions by counselors
and received chat
and item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committees
councilor Hinton
chairman
um nothing was actually referred to to
us
but we were asked to comment on the
joint parking strategy and it was also
felt uh that we ought to comment on the
council tax reduction working age
scheme
on Friday the 30th of September joint
overview and Scoot and he met and uh
over a period of about
two hours
discussed the parking strategy in some
detail
scrutiny welcomes the parking strategy
and has the following comments
members expressed concern over the
uncertainty in predicting parking
capacity and expressing the need to
update predictions of car use and car
park use as the project moves into the
implementation phase
there were queries over the governance
of parking strategy implementation and a
request that the business case for the
implementation plan be made available
for scrutiny at an appropriate time
also information bulletins at Key stages
of the implementation implementation
phase
mm-hmm the collected data shows that
some 40 to 50 percent of Journeys to a
car park are one and a half miles or
less
the strategy needs to encourage
implementation of proposals to
discourage car use by providing
opportunities for Journeys to be
undertaken by other means
this will involve working with Partners
including Suffolk County Council and the
sustainable travel officer
members ask why there was no data on
problem areas and suggested producing a
heat map showing reported instances of
enforcement and issuing of penalty
notice charges in Hot Spot areas
emphasis needs to be made on trip
reduction not increasing the number of
car parking spaces
the strategy seems to accept that
spending Town centers increases when on
on-street parking is permitted
officers should be asked to review case
studies conducted in towns where the
reverse has been shown to be the case
members Express concern about the lack
of flexibility in the strategy
data was collected before the sharp
increase in fuel prices and the cost of
living crisis
transport to school often leads to
on-street parking
a strategy for reducing the problems
caused by parent parking needs to be
developed probably with Suffolk County
Council
members suggested that work is needed to
investigate the often unsatisfactory
parking of vehicles for car and Van
sharing particularly along the A14
corridor
and I would like to add it happens
elsewhere as well
members agreed that the strategy has a
limited scope as most car parking spaces
are under the control of others
especially on street parking
something like 90 of the parking within
the two districts is controlled by the
County Council because it's effectively
on-street parking
members are not persuaded that the
strategy could be used to influence
planning policy
those were the the
agreed concerns of the overview and
scrutiny committee to bring forward to
both cabinets
members of the cabinet do any of you
have any questions for councilor Hinton
or any comments on anything he has said
councilor Osborne
thank you Mr Jim um I'm a little bit
surprised actually that scrutiny haven't
identified the issue that we've got on
um parking on our green verges and on
our open space I listened very carefully
so I apologize if I've missed it but I
didn't hear that there nor also and I'm
going to raise a question when we go
into questions for cabinet on the need
for a lorry Park to replace the current
one that we've got in Sudbury so they're
just two it's more a statement really
than a question I'm surprised that
scrutiny didn't pick up on those two
really important
scrutiny we're looking at the process
rather than the actual
detailed content of the proposals which
is what they're they're only are are
required to do
there was a lot of a lot of discussion
about its things like on-road parking
Etc but a lot of it was outside of the
control of the district council and
therefore outside the scope of overview
and scrutiny to influence the
the production of a strategy
councilor Gould thank you chuck could
you just repeat your last sentence that
you had councilor Hinton please from
overview and scrutiny
I didn't quite catch it that on Street
on street parking which includes Burgess
is within the remit of the County
Council as the highways Authority and
not within the remit of the district
council and therefore was outside the
scope of overview and scrutiny to
actually comment
okay
this
Council agents I thank you for that
um those are all very helpful and I
think
we'll be able to take some of those
forward and work on
at one point Mr chairman and that is on
the on the point about car and Van
sharing particularly along the A14
corridor this is becoming an increasing
problem and when you look at the car
parking provision off-street car parking
provision across the districts
the vast majority of it is in
Parish Owned Car parks that are
associated with Village Halls Etc and if
they are filled up with people parking
there to then go off in a joint car down
to somewhere else it causes a major
problem when they have events on in
terms of providing adequate parking for
the people using the village Halls
because those spaces are taking up order
but it's not it's not included within
this the only part carb opt street car
parkings that are included are the ones
owned by the district councils I
understand that that is um
accept that as an admission and we do
need to incorporate that
thank you very much councilor Hinton
thank you
councilman crawl
thank you chair
um
looking at the recommendations made by
overview and scrutiny I'm just trying to
sort of apply them as to how they could
be used within the recommendations in
the report Main and it seems to me that
the particularly the third point I'm
just going to move between two documents
with the second and third points about
further work
demands for Alternatives and that
brought and due progress reports be
supplied it seems to me that those could
easily be accommodated within the third
recommendation
in front of us in the main papers which
we have lost for a second
yes thank you guys you've got the point
yeah I I understand that and I agree
with you there thank you
right if there are no further questions
then we will move on
to the next item
so it's item seven the forthcoming
decisions list does anyone have any
comments on the forthcoming decisions
list
nope
excellent
right but moving on then to the next
item item eight which is paper BCA 2225
the baber mid-suffolk parking strategy
2022-2042
unfortunately the cabinet member for the
environment councilman VC can't be with
us today she is suffering from the flu
and
so you've got me introducing the report
on her behalf
I'm pleased to use the baber and
Midsouth at parking strategy
2022-2042 to provide a joined up
strategy that covers not just the
details of on street and off Street
provision but also the economic
environmental and Community impacts of
parking
it also needs to incorporate how parking
complaints part in our response to the
climate emergency by encouraging changes
to car use
the workman's commissioned following the
cabinet decision in August 2021 and it
builds upon previous work of the joint
area parking management plan which was
prepared four years ago in the run-up to
the implementation of civil parking
enforcement and which provides detail on
how the Suffolk parking management
strategy will be implemented locally and
the parking study report prepared in
2021 in which documents all aspects of
the current parking provision
this strategy is of course Very
wide-ranging and has taken 14 months to
prepare there have been a number of
stages investigation and data collection
member and town and Parish Council
briefings public engagement analysis of
the data and engagement feedback and
preparation of the strategy with its
recommendations
the strategy is designed to help support
our vision for baber and midsucker which
is to build great communities with
bright and healthy Futures that everyone
is proud to call home by shaping the
future growth of the districts enhancing
the quality of the local environment as
well as providing prospectus for
investment through regeneration of our
town centers and Rural villages
the parking strategy is a key means of
enhancing our already strong and vibrant
districts and reinforces the importance
of everyone having access to sufficient
safe and easy to use parking facilities
for cars and other vehicles
at suitable hours of the day or night
the strategy at a high level needs to
identify parking demand and supply for
the next 20 years it needs to reflect
National guidance as it applies to both
the future of town centers and commuting
patterns reflect the changing needs of
transport and as far as this is possible
anticipate patterns of demand and most
importantly be capable of adaptation
the detail of why how and what we will
do to make this a reality is explained
in the document
at the heart of this strategy is the
principle that there is sufficient
parking provision for all in appropriate
locations to ensure the success of our
communities in the local economy and to
enhance the quality of the environment
the strategy contains recommendations
that we believe can bring real change to
how we travel and how we deliver the
wider Ambitions for our communities and
places
today in front of you we have a number
of reports attached to the cabinet paper
there's a concise version of strategy of
dependency a detailed report a
dependence B the 2021 parking study of
appendix C and the consultation feedback
reports that dependencies d
finally I'd like to thank all involved
in the production of this very
comprehensive and impressive strategy
a Cabinet member for the environment
councilman VC
her predecessor councilor Dawson who
worked on the foundations of the
strategy
and of course our officers and finally
2020 consultancy they've all played a
part in and have all worked really hard
to produce an excellent document
so therefore I'm pleased to propose the
recommendations in Section 3 of the
report and I'd like to ask for a second
councilman craw
L members of the cabinet are there any
questions
councilor Osborne
thank you Mr
chair yeah I've already
a relocated Lorry Park you've got the
issues now with the one on the a14s
closing down and also there's huge
problems down churchfield Road in
Sudbury
and the surrounding areas and some of
the rural areas surrounding Sudbury as
well so we do need a new Lorry Park and
I know the officers promised us that we
would have some information on that so
I'm hoping something is forthcoming
today before we approve this strategy
and the other one is open space and I
appreciate that you've made it much more
robust now in the strategy which is good
but I would ask the question on how do
we propose to get this address these
concerns addressed with the considerable
parking on open space and green areas
thank you Mr chairman
and good afternoon everyone I I'll try
and then I'll probably bring in some
colleagues to give a little bit more
information so in terms of the Lorry
park I think we have uh added some
additional information into the public
pack report
um with regard to Lorry parking
um I think the the sort of long-term
strategic piece and the immediate issues
are kind of slightly different things so
um we are in the process of having or
trying to set up a meeting with the
County Council to talk about the kind of
immediate issues
um the longer term issues I might just
defer to my colleagues
um because I think there's a sort of
slightly longer strategic conversation
that that is
regard to a strategy around
Lorry parking and activity so if I can
defer to Sarah or Sharon thank you
thank you good afternoon thank you ever
so much
um so we have spoken or we are speaking
with Suffolk County Council who are also
reviewing um suffolk-wide Lorry parking
facilities and also the travel routes
throughout Suffolk that the Lorry
drivers may need to take and making sure
that areas in which we have current
Lorry parks at the moment are identified
so it is going to lead on to further
work so we have in its within your
public pack on page 84 is 8.8 of the
update
um outlined the need for Lorry parks to
be reviewed following our last briefing
session
and also our Suffolk County Council to
keep us informed on their work that
they're doing with their local transport
plan also so that we understand what the
picture looks forward as we move as we
move forward with our implementation
plan we can make sure we include the
correct links within our documents and
so our parking strategy along with their
transport plan are joined up and also
take into the needs of Lorry drivers in
the facilities that they may need
thank you
and then I'll pick up on the um Verge
parking if I may
um so yeah following the cabinet
briefing um we updated both the strategy
summary and the strategy report to
incorporate a reference to open space
parking
um with regards to the implementation
plan
there will be an absolute need for
further work further conversations with
yourselves as counselors and town and
Parish councils to identify specific
locations across the district where open
that open space parking is called is
causing a problem so yeah we will work
closely with yourselves and other
offices across the organization and to
bring that about through the
implementation plan
thank you
thank you
Council McLaren
thank you
well first of all I want to say that
creating this
report if it was to be compared to
reading it I think you've done a great
job it's a lot of a lot of information
and you've worked really hard at it I've
just got two questions and I don't know
who's going to answer this given the
interaction with the public so that was
questionnaires and
um
comments made by the public that was in
the region of just over 3 000 people
given and and that was Midsummer and
baber together I think given that the
total population was 195
000.
was that a reasonable response for a
survey so I thought Adam might know the
answer to this was that a reasonable
response for a survey like we've
undertaken
foreign
thank you
um so we've parking strategies
um it's challenging to sort of put a
percentage of how much of the population
you should be engaging with often those
are getting involved the ones that sort
of have a particular interest over it
um so to sort of allocate a percentage
against the population I'd say is
challenging what I would say is I've
been involved in well over 30 parking
strategies across the country and this
is by some distance that the highest
engagement rate that we've ever had by
some distance and the the feedback that
we had was from a variety of different
age groups from different areas across
the two districts so the sample size was
was excellent in terms of sort of the
feedback that we we had so from our
perspective it met all the sort of the
criteria that was looking to as part of
the engagement process
so uh thank you Adam my second question
is probably for Fiona really
um Fiona you know what a supporter I am
of the virtual High Street
with that sort of developing over covid
and all of that
that's that impacted the thoughtful in
Hadley and Sudbury
um we don't actually have sort of
football counters in either of those
towns
um so it's quite difficult to say in you
know detailed terms what the impact is
like to be
um I think when it relates back to
parking though I'm not sure that we've
seen any particular impact on parking
changes so I think very much anecdotally
people are still very much coming into
the into the High Street and doing their
shopping I think the virtual High Street
is is as is intended is a complementary
measure which can allow people to trade
online as well as having their High
Street so it's a sort of boost for their
High Street presence so we're not
anticipating that it should have an
impact significantly on parking
yeah well that's reassuring because we
wouldn't want to implement something
else you find it as a not going to
affect somewhere else so thank you thank
you chair
and uh I I I'd agree with that we don't
want the virtual High Street to um it is
meant to be an addition rather than a
replacement for people going into town
and I think that the um vastly increased
provision of of places to have snacks
lunches coffees that sort of thing that
that's the draw that brings people in
excuse me so that they will come in and
spend time in town and then use the
shops so um uh and that's the sort of
High Street we want to see going forward
any other questions
yeah it's a question for Adam I think he
just said I think you said you've
completed 30 of these across the country
and just following on from councilor
Osborne's question I wondered if you
would usually pick up the issue of Lorry
parking or not
so it's it's picked up in the sense of
it's important for for the districts to
to acknowledge where its position is um
in in terms of the delivery mechanisms
um as a local Highway authority
responsibility to deliver so what we are
identifying is the need for that liaison
with Suffolk County Council and for them
to sort of work with baber and
mid-suffolk officers to determine the
locations that are suitable for Lorry
parks and the facilities that are
provided and all the the costs and and
benefits and business case should be
sort of done in terms of sort of cross
cross
relationship working so the
acknowledgment is that yes it's
something that should be picked up and
it's important that that is signposted
in both sort of what babe and
mid-suffolk had taken for but also what
Suffolk County Council were also taking
forward
it's not really another question but I
can't help thinking that perhaps we
missed a trip German when we did this I
think we probably should have
highlighted the issue of Laurie parking
earlier on
um because we were aware of it however I
think this strategy is due for review
within three to five years
and we've already alerted and picked up
and of course the work to provide a new
Lorry part with facilities will actually
take some years to to bring to fruition
won't it
yes okay
okay
oh
I'd just like to ask again I don't know
who but um I think for reassurances to
the general public as well that this is
a living document it's a 20-year
document we're going to be uh well I
wonder if you could just give us a a
brief run-through of the review process
that will take place on the strategy
over the next 20 years we've seen in the
last few years already credible changes
in transport use they may have been very
short term a year or two here or there
but when you've got empty empty roads
for example as we saw not only not not
two years ago and then you know within
the matter of uh lockdown ceasing
traffic levels had risen I think in
Suffolk by four percent on pre-pandemic
levels that's
a massive amount of change and I think
it's likely we're going to see further
changes so I just think it should be
good to reassure people that this is a
an ongoing process for
till 2042.
somebody just explain how that will be
handled
um I'll certainly pick it up initially
and the strategy uh you're absolutely
right things are changing all the time
and the strategy as everyone's already
pointed out has had an enormous amount
of work and background studies that have
gone into it I don't think we're
proposing to update that every every
year or anything
um but I think we're looking at three to
five year review periods over that 20
year I think
um whilst today isn't about the
implementation plan obviously the next
stage of work the really important stage
of work is a living and breathing
implementation plan and that as and when
business cases are required we will of
course double check background
information current data as part of that
business case process so certainly for
those bigger recommendations
um it will have very current up-to-date
information that feed into the business
case so the strategy will be reviewed
um fairly regularly but the
implementation plan will be living and
breathing
Council McLaren
thank you
um I was just in the light of what
councilman cross said
just all this potential moving forward
have implications for the resources
within
um out of the department that's going to
deal with this
um
resources in its General sense as in
staff resources and financial resource
yes it will do which is why
um certainly again with those larger
recommendations those bigger schemes as
part of the business case we'll have to
look at the resources that that I used
um it's probably worth pointing out at
this moment though that the
implementation plan that sits
um within the strategy and the
recommendations in fact in the strategy
there's a mix of sort of
big and small projects and and some of
those smaller projects which we would
hope we can Implement very quickly and
not particularly time resource or
resource resource so hopefully there'll
be a blend but but certainly with those
bigger projects as with any big project
we will make sure at the beginning of
those projects we do a proper resource
review
thank you
any other question Council gold
um it's it's a concern really which I
can sort of frame as a question page 18
4.7 and it's picked up again in the
actual strategy where it speaks about
and and you know we've heard that the
data was collected Joy of August of 21
which was covered
um is it the bus data
is there an algorithm or remote tricks
that will make some kind of allowance
for the fact that it was a covered slump
it's been raised um several times
through the process
um
the the need for data collection was
predominantly to set Baseline data for
our for our forecasting so uh it was a
sort of an early stage process what we
have sort of worked towards is that
generally speaking yes there was even
there's no actual restrictions in place
due to covid there was this was still
within that sort of post-covered world
where where for a lot of residents they
might not felt comfortable going to the
sort of town centers Etc so we're
expecting to see a reduction potentially
so our threshold in terms of the
occupancy rates that we was looking at
we did produce slightly sort of take
that on board alongside that sort of and
this is sort of a generic nationally
sort of a
research has been carried out outside of
this up the the pre-Christmas rush so
the summer holidays is traditionally one
of the busier times of the year for car
parking usage so whilst there's likely
to be a reduction through through that
post-covid situation
um is also likely to be increases in
many of the car Parks due to the summer
holidays when the surveys were carried
up
thank you and I guess
um vast difference in data will be
picked up at the as you say field of the
implementation stage
can I ask as well
top of page 21.
where it actually says
well drop a page 22 really
um
no top of page 21 the council may be
perceived to be untrustworthy and have a
poor reputation
and the the bit that concerns me as you
would expect the council will not be
carbon neutral by 2030 which is a bit of
a concern but is that at odds and at
variance with page 32 where the Suffolk
climate change partnership is saying
that Suffolk is hoping to be carbon
neutral I couldn't quite marry up those
two sentences in my mind
okay yes thank you Alistair consider
that answered
thank you Council McGraw
sorry that's okay
right
um are there any further questions
if not oh Council Busby
question ordered item for debate really
there are going to be elements in here
that we won't be able to resolve issues
which the public may think because we've
got the strategy we're going to find
answers to everything like parking on
verges in Council Estates or housing
Estates
where there's
little alternative for the residents
what other risks are there do you think
what other items are there where you
think we're not going to be able to find
a solution or if we are it's going to be
a very long term
I think it's going to be me
um
that's quite a difficult question to
answer I mean obviously the strategy is
prepared based on the evidence the
evidence is demonstrated and developed a
range of recommendations
um some will be easier than others for a
range of reasons and as as we've already
discussed at times change so you know it
might be that we Embark upon a
um a particular project own to find
conditions change and we can't deliver
it it's very difficult for me at this
stage to give you that kind of uh
honest answer about what they're likely
to be and but what I would say is that
the strategy is based upon the evidence
and it's developed recommendations of
what needs to happen whether that
whether that will happen or not and as I
said before when we get to the
individual business cases
um there may be valid reasons why we
can't do some of that stuff but as it
stands at the moment the recommendations
are what the evidence is telling us I
don't know if Adam wants to come in
I mean it's it's a good example that you
raise with the Verge parking because
what we've done is is this strategy is
being developed at a strategic level to
cover District while districts wide and
once once approved if approved we'll be
looking to apply that at a local level
and with the Verge parking for instance
that's one that potentially might be
easier to to mitigate in some locations
compared to others and then even within
those specific locations there could be
different sort of treatments in effect
that you'd be looking at for instance is
is Verge parking occurring because
there's just nowhere else to park or is
it occurring because people are just
more convenient parking on the verge
because it's closest to where they want
to be so sort of identifying those sort
of answers will help then determine sort
of the mitigations to that so what we've
identified within that this strategy is
is several of the
um the recommendations are sort of Taken
what we've identified at this sort of
strategic level and then looking to sort
of develop more detailed studies which
will be more location specific and by
that we should be able to sort of
identify those issues and there's no
reason why they can't be sort of risk
plans or associated with those studies
to identify what the risks are and how
we can mitigate them and potentially
they can be used
even though it could be sort of
locations specific there could be sort
of appliables certainly in terms of the
risks in other locations to sort of
determine what can and can't be done so
as Fiona was saying it's very difficult
to sort of identify what we may or may
not be able to sort of resolve in terms
of risk but certainly with those
projects that will be sort of needing to
go into the more the greater detail at
the location specific
um basis I expect for us to be able to
sort of resolve the vast majority them
so whilst we might be able to do that
now through the development of those
sort of studies we expect to be able to
sort of find resolutions to the vast
majority if not all those sort of
parking related matters
well that's good news I'll be surprised
but um the other thing is you've had a
good response to on the surveys you know
three thousand odd people which is fine
and I think Mary said there's 195 000
people in there it might be the 3 000
people that are desperate to get cut
parking sorted out the other hundred and
ninety two thousand might be desperate
for parking not to be sorted out I.E for
people to sort out bikes and pedestrians
and buses rather than
have you taken that into consideration
so um our parking strategy does um link
very um closely with the LC Whip and the
sustainable travel Vision there are also
sections within the strategy
um that um that touch on um the highways
infrastructure so public transport for
example
um and we also consider those that may
walk or cycle into so those town and
Village locations as well so when we
talk about parking and Improvement of
parking we're also looking at
motorcycles
there's some section in there around
motorhomes as well and the potential for
Coach coach parking and also car clubs
and um you know sort of sharing sharing
car services so
um I think as Adam alluded to earlier
whilst is that strategic level there is
very much it's a piece of a wider a
wider jigsaw
in terms of your initial question about
um areas which are going to be more
difficult to implement I guess that
there are three and one of which is is
the um the modal shift and encouraging
that and that's going to take some some
time and will involve other
organizations particularly County
Council and bus operators
but also um for instance
increasing parking provision it when we
reach or exceed thresholds for
um the the use of car parks in in
certain locations that that's not going
to be an easy one to to address and and
thirdly I think
um uh residents on street parking
provision where uh in some streets that
there is already contention for
residents places and that's not not
going to be an easy one either so I
think those are three that
um we do realize are going to be
difficult and um will require
time money and working with others
councilman crawl did you have a question
it's less of this specific to this
report and more for information for all
members of the council and the cabinet
and particularly of today's Busby's so
our question about risk management
because risk management has recently
been transferred from as an or from
being an audit function into my
portfolio which is customers and and
digital transformation
um and a complete review of the risk
management across the council's
operations is taking place a new risk
management register uh risk management
approach a more systematic approach and
less purely the financial approach that
was previously to the case when it was
considered purely under audit we know
that there are Financial risks to be
managed but we also know that there are
others that we have just been referring
to uh
the papers and so on so I just thought
I'd throw that in as a general piece of
information because I think it's going
to become each directorate will be part
of the risk management process dealing
directly with my director up to to to
pull it all together and apply a
consistent approach across the board
rather than a piecemeal one I just hope
that helps
thank you councilor um we're kind of
moving into debate now which is no bad
thing
um councilor McLaren thank you chair I
just had a quick question
um
we've been talking about grass verges
now this comes up in planning
applications and the question I was
going to put to perhaps Fiona or the
team is there some possible future link
of this strategy with planning
applications because certainly most of
the applications that I've signed on
there's always been some concern that
parking has been insufficient on the
development and part and grass verges so
is that a possibility or
no I don't know if Sharon wants to come
in after me but certainly we see this
document being very similar to the local
walking transport
um walking and cycling infrastructure
plan that we've developed which is uh
which will enable us to have very early
conversations uh with planning officers
about specific schemes at that
pre-application stage and and that seems
to be working really well from the LC
whip perspective so we anticipate doing
the same thing with this strategy it
sort of sets a direction of travel that
will enable us to have those
conversations at the earliest possible
stage when major applications come in
thank you thank you
right so um moving into debate does
anyone wish to have any comments um any
observations
councilman Goulding councilor Osborne
it's an observation really
[Music]
I thought oh that's really Innovative uh
on the way back to the 1950s
I wouldn't know
oh
my God I've seen something Saturday I've
seen the films okay so I thought I
thought that was a wonderful idea and
also the idea to um possibly allow
motorhomes Park ing space overnight so
well done whoever came up with those I
thought they were great
councilor Osborne
I've really been long anticipated
there's a lot of expectancy coming out
of it
um and I really want to thank all the
time and effort that officers I know
have put into this I think it's a really
good document and also members of the
public that have made comments into it
that have been useful and productive I'm
sure in producing this strategy itself
I'm really pleased that we've taken the
incentive to drive a strategy forward we
didn't have to because if you look at
the action plan A lot of it is down to
Suffolk County Council so there again
I'm going to make a point that I do
really hope that Suffolk County Council
will come up trumps on this one and work
with us to deliver this because
otherwise the delivery plan will fall
flat on its face
and as I've said to offices before
actually the proof of the pudding in
this strategy is going to be in the
delivery of the of the action plan so I
look forward to seeing that happening
um but I just want to thank officers for
all the time that they've put into I
think it's an excellent strategy and I'm
looking forward to our grass verges
being clear of cars parked on them and
then councilor beer will give me a bit
of a rest on that one at every four
Council that we come to but no seriously
um that is a real issue and one that
does need to be addressed and councilor
McLaren is absolutely right we need to
address it
in the in the in the planning stage how
many developments do we see come forward
where they've got some lovely green open
space but it's kept unprotected from the
risk of cars or fans being allowed or
lorries come to that being allowed to
park on it so I do hope that this
strategy really drives forward decisions
that are being made at planning as well
so thank you officers for all your hard
work thank you
any other comments
you got some Busby
um that in anything that's going to be
things that you can do in the short term
and things that are going to take a long
time
as the portfolio holder for finance I
hope
all going to be cost neutral
otherwise you might not find that this
uh unanimous support for this strategy
[Music]
it's a fair comment Council Busby um we
know that um any Improvement has to
if at all possible fund itself so income
generation
is always something that we we need to
to look to
um
at the council it's an increasing part
of our overall income
and um
when it comes to parking that's no
different from any other service that's
um
essentially discretionary rather than
statutory service so um
we will look forward to that in the
future
any other comments
born just one last thing can I just
thank uh Alistair for his information on
risk management risk analysis as Emily
knows I'm a real fan of risk management
and risk analysis and um please send me
anything that you've got on it
I'm happy to do that actually and uh um
as soon as I worked out how it works
myself I know I have got some experience
but I mean we are literally developing
the strategy uh the risk management
spreadsheets I have a meeting
um the next later this month
um be happy to keep you in the loop
okay well um if that's it uh we'll move
to the vote in a minute but I would like
to once again say thank you to everyone
involved in producing this Fiona Sarah
and of course Adam from 2020 consultancy
and thank you all it's it's an excellent
document there's a massive amount of
information in here
particularly the um the response from
from the public feedback and the
analysis of that which makes a very
interesting reading and um uh and also
uh encouraging because it's quite clear
that members of the public do understand
the the issues at play here and and have
um and a reasonable in what they want to
see going forward and that they know
that uh we need to do things but they
also understand that um
a lot of a lot of this may not
necessarily be what everyone would like
to see but they realize that it's uh
it's necessary to to make sure we've got
the right sort of Department provisioned
in the district for the next 20 years so
thank you all for that
okay then we'll move on to the vote
please yeah
your chair the vote's
chair that is seven votes four and
that's unanimous thank you
oh okay then moving on to the next item
item nine paper BCA 2226 exemption of
right to buy receipts for Newcastle
housing from pooling I'd like to invite
the cabinet member for finance assets
and Investments to introduce this report
councilor Busby over to you
thank you chair
uh well I think
this is going to be very short because I
think the paper is very clear
by applying for the exemption it gives
us flexibility in how we use right to
buy receipts
and there are no downsides
current risk right to buy rules are very
restrictive
having the exemption would allow us to
spend the receipts on affordable housing
regeneration projects or repaying HRA
debt
the scope that we're looking at at the
end of March this year just over 200
houses qualified for this exemption
how many will qualify of course we don't
know because we don't know how many
right to buy sales are going to be going
forward
to me this is one of those things that
we should accept very gratefully and
therefore I propose we approve the
exemption application and ask for a
second thank you
thank you
members of the cabinet any questions
councilor Osborne
Mr chairman
um obviously this was introduced in uh
by the on the first of April 2022 and
we're now six months down the line
so I'm just wondering if there's any
monies we've lost by this not being
approved back in April unless my
understanding is correct and there's a
retrospect where we can go back to 2008.
yeah I can take this one thank you for
your question
um so there is a retrospective
application so we can go back and apply
for for that retrospectively to to move
those receipts and it doesn't change the
amount for Capital receipts that we will
receive and so we won't get any
additional back for it but we'll have
more flexibility in how we use that so
rather than have to use it for a one for
one replacement
you can use it for any purpose that we
wish
and I mean it helps the right to buy
schemers positively skewed against us
um in the past and it was a ridiculous
scheme
how we were supposed to produce a
one-for-one like for like replacement
when they when the government managed to
take away most of the funds that we got
from selling the house
um so this is a small step in trying to
get that corrected I think
questions
no anyone wish to make any comments in
debate
you want to move to the vote okay
sorry you were too quick for me there
the vote is now in progress
foreign
that is seven votes for that unanimous
chair thank you
right item 10 paper BCA 22 27. the
council tax reduction working age scheme
2023-2024 and this is a consultation for
this and I'd like to invite the cabinet
member for finance assets and
Investments to introduce the report
councilor Busby again
thanks well this may be even shorter
maybe not but uh Henry get ready for the
vote
uh
with these anything like this we should
be aiming for maximum benefits with
minimum costs
increasing the maximum from 95 to 100
percent
but uh
in need
and simplifying the uh
the UC scheme
under options two or three
should do this
and also
make it cheaper for us to
administer
so I think anything where you can get a
benefit and have the benefit paid for by
efficiency is a good news
scheme 3 will probably be slightly more
expensive than seeing scheme 2 or option
two but it does protect those households
that would be worse off
under the simplified scheme so I would
propose that we do go for option three
and that we agree to go out to
consultation on that
and I asked for a second on that thank
you
councilor Osborne
chairman I support this
absolutely
um my my question is with option three
there aren't going to be any people that
miss out on this are there does it make
sure that we cover all groups because
sometimes we do a recommendation on an
option and then there's a few that fall
into the gaps so is there any that fall
into this one
yeah I'm not sure I can actually answer
that question without going back to SRP
just to double check on that analysis
but obviously once we've done the
consultation we'll bring back more of
that rounded data and that complete data
to show you if there are any people that
fall out so we've got that complete data
I think with the excellent Provisions in
in option three over and above the the
option two with the additional people
that will be caught by biology probably
reduces that number to pretty much zero
but um obviously it'd be useful to get
srp's analysis on that thank you
Council crawl this after all is just to
go to consultation not to make a final
decision so effectively there's no
reason for any delay whatsoever when it
comes back then we make the decision but
um we're looking to provide cover to a
greater extent for and it's not a very
large number of people we don't want it
to be a large number of people but there
should be something a safety net and the
safety net should be well should have as
few holes in it as possible
okay well we kind of moved into debate
there again
um does anyone else have any
further comments on this
oh Council McLaren
thank you no I think it's to be welcomed
actually and looking at the
other age from a cost of living crisis
respect to the communities looking out
that's going to help other
agencies that work with us I think is
um to be welcomed and I think the SRP
costs that in itself
um I mean I'm amazed how much money
we're going to possibly save so yes I'm
all for this scheme
certainly an important consideration
than the savings there and especially if
labor Midsouth at nets which all do the
same thing that's that's um I need to be
welcome
okay then uh we'll move to the vote
oh you've got another question
Jan's already second
yes please Henry thank you chair the
voters
thank you that is seven words four and
that's unanimous chair okay
um thank you very much for that
um before that was the last item before
I closed the meeting I just wanted to
say a few words about our monitoring
officer I'm not going to repeat
everything I said earlier and but I just
just wanted to say
um we are sadly losing our monitoring
officer Emily Ewell she has been an
excellent monitoring officer for the two
councils she'll be greatly missed I
don't know how we're going to find
somebody so good but we will have to do
so
um but she does have a a well-deserved
and a great opportunity to further her
career and I think we all wish her the
very best for the future but thank you
for everything you've done for us Emily
and I hope you have a great great time
in your new job
[Applause]
and with that I will close the meeting
the next meeting scheduled for the 7th
of November 2PM